okay take two I think we should be live
this time around so I'm looking on the
other screen I'm not sure I'm seeing us
oh there's a bit of a delay there's a
bit of a uh I think 30 seconds yeah we
could ask the chat if they see us yep
does everyone see us and hear us okay
we're good
okay it should be good okay yes this is
take two uh yeah sorry everyone for a
couple minutes late but yeah we're live
now and welcome to another tech with
Lucy live stream today I'm here with
Linda a developer Advocate at AWS and
we're here to share our advice on how to
learn AWS cloud in 2023. some questions
we'll be covering include how to gain
Hands-On Cloud experience how to set a
study plan and what resources we
recommend using hey Linda how are you
doing today I'm doing great how are you
we had a funny uh moment where we were
we thought we were live and we weren't
so sorry y'all for the delay
um everything's great it's night time in
New York just about like 6 p.m it looks
like nine and I know it's like morning
for you Lucy yes morning 10 a.m here for
me different sides of the world but glad
we could find a time that our lines
um so Linda we met over a video call for
the first time around the end of last
year and you know we had a chat but I
remember seeing you all the time on
Instagram and Tick Tock even before you
joined AWS you've made such a big impact
in the tech community over the years but
for viewers who haven't come across you
before do you want to introduce yourself
and walk us through your career Journey
yeah absolutely and first of all Lucy
I've been such a fan and seeing all your
work on LinkedIn and YouTube so it's so
great to be live with you um you are
doing such amazing work hi everyone I'm
Linda I'm a developer Advocate at AWS
and my journey was untraditional uh into
Tech I was a philosophy major in college
I did not know anything about tech in
college
um and I actually went to a coding boot
camp in short I'm summarizing this but I
went to a coding bootcamp after two
years of working in TV production and
start it out as a JavaScript developer
as a front-end web developer then kind
of because I was doing a lot of
JavaScript started doing more uh API
type work node.js and slowly shifted
more into also back end and then got
into Cloud worked as an SRE worked as an
infrastructure engineer and now working
as a AWS developer advocate so that's
kind of the cliff notes
um but it's been an amazing journey and
I kind of like calling myself a
professional student because I feel like
I'm always just learning something new
which is
which is fun which is why it this it's
what uh it's what excited me excites me
about this industry
awesome we have a few questions coming
in already which is good
um and yeah for those who are tuning in
please comment below where you're tuning
in from so Linda's in New York I'm in
Sydney and maybe also tell us what time
it is over there for you uh but yeah so
so good to have you here today on the
live stream Linda we have five questions
already prepared uh you know I just did
a quick poll asking people what sort of
questions they were answered so let me
just pull this up on the screen but
today will it'll be quite a casual q a
style conversation where you know
sometimes I'll go over some of the
questions on the screen and then we'll
also take some questions from the
audience but what I really wanted to ask
you first and we've talked a bit about
this before the live stream is how can a
beginner get started with AWS Cloud how
can they you know like set a study plan
and create like a roadmap so that they
can work towards their dream role in the
cloud industry yeah so it's such a great
question and actually one thing that I
always start by saying is the beauty of
tech in general in the cloud industry is
that there's so much information online
there's so many free resources and what
makes it accessible is also what makes
it overwhelming right because it may be
it there's so many options and so many
different directions it's sometimes hard
to know where to start what to do and I
think the journey and the road map for
cloud really depends on what your
starting point is and your use of
transferable skills I like to just tell
everybody the caveat working in cloud is
not only Cloud skills right so there's
so many other skills that go into Cloud
roles and cloud in general is Broad so
what I like to tell people if you don't
know where to start depending if you're
a beginner or already working in Tech
your journey might look quite different
but the main thing I I personally
recommend doing because this is kind of
like how for me and my personal
experience this helped me with starting
with fundamentals and when I say cloud
fundamentals I mean you know knowing
just the depending on maybe like
different core practices you could have
there's a lot of courses like on skill
Builder and other places that kind of
give cover confidentials to the point
that you could start understanding the
different roles because when you're
trying to understand the different roles
there are and what your goal is it could
be really hard to those roles could vary
with skill sets right there's a lot of
different types of roles in Cloud so you
have to get to a point in my opinion to
know enough fundamentals to then
identify a role and work backwards
um so my step one would be study Cloud
fundamentals get familiar with the type
of jobs there are
and also when you when you're trying to
look up jobs in that phase where you're
just trying to get familiar networking
going to meetups learning and listening
to other people in the industry I think
that kind of applies to anything in Tech
when you're trying to break into it you
kind of need to understand the industry
a bit and the location you're in and the
opportunities available in the location
you're in because those vary as well the
businesses are in different phases and
so they might look for different skill
sets and jobs
the other thing is so that's like step
one sorry so like to summarize that step
one fundamentals you don't have to know
exactly where you're going don't get
into action paralysis just start with
like understanding what is the cloud
what are the core uh things to choose
like maybe there's YouTube Cloud
fundamentals there's Lucy does a great
job there's skillbuilder.aws if you want
to learn there's free courses on there
uh just to learn the cloud fundamentals
and start figuring out those different
roles the the second thing I would say
is kind of the part of the first thing
is the meetups and also like once you
understand the fundamentals
um really looking into what those job
requirements are
um
because when people say learn Cloud
there are other skills like networking
Linux programming languages you might
not need to know all of them for a cloud
rule right but maybe the different roles
you're choosing might need those skill
sets or might help you to know those
things so work backwards go on LinkedIn
look at the job roles in your area in
your dream companies because those roles
vary and even the titling varies
sometimes the solution architect in one
company might be doing something a
little different than what a solution
architect maybe at Amazon is doing or
the requirements for that so I think
using the network you have as well
throughout all of that is really
important
um and for me like that helps just a
little bit of background like I came
from like front-end development into
cloud and I was I transitioned in the
same company and I also worked in TV
production in the same company I worked
a non-technical role and transitioned
into Tech within the same company so my
point is if you're in a company that
already has technical roles that's
another way to do that so right it
really depends what your starting point
is
um but study fundamentals figure out the
jobs are they in the company you're
working in are they outside of the
company you're working in right from
there
um I would then kind of like
if you're still not sure after Cloud
fundamentals I recommend doing the
solution architect if you know you want
to use AWS and AWS is what's popular in
your area I would I recommend going for
the associate solution architect because
a certification and even if you're not
taking the certification it's broad so
it introduces you to all these different
services and that could kind of
familiarize yourself a bit more but Lucy
I'm going to pause here and just kind of
get your thoughts as well on what I'm
six or five percent that you want to add
because I know like you have a lot of
experience as well doing this and
suggesting this
so many good points there I like how you
mentioned that learning cloud isn't just
about watching videos and you know like
going by a book and trying to just learn
all the theory you also talked about
networking which is a really important
part because sometimes you know trying
to put everything you learned into
helping other people or just meeting
people who are also in the community
doing the same thing you're doing with
learning AWS and trying to learn a role
that's really important and definitely a
part of the learning process
um
I think you yeah definitely agree with
all of that advice in that you learn the
cloud fundamentals first and then from
there you can start figuring out which
role is right for you whether you want
to become a cloud engineer and Associate
Solutions architect or potentially you
want to start off with the more
traditional route of working in tech
support or help desk and then trying to
transition into a cloud role but there's
so many opportunities these days because
you know some people do start from the
traditional background I started off
starting you know as an intern at AWS
and then transitioning into the graduate
program that AWS offers for associate
Solutions Architects and you know like
people like yourself starting from
completely different Industries but you
can still use a lot of the skills that
they've gained from previous Industries
into their role which I think is pretty
cool so another uh question which brings
us to question number two is I want to
ask more about the specific resources
used to learn AWS cloud or ones that you
recommend and then you know as you you
talk about them I'll just drop the links
into the comments yeah and just to
summarize real quick the last the the
roadmap Point
um I'm I think like it kind of ties into
the advice and resources and all that
your journey is going to look very
different somebody is asking here about
like how do we land the role if there's
they're asking for experience I I think
um when you're learning let's say let's
say you just start with uh
certifications as a guide even if you
don't take the certification you can use
the material as a guide but the main
thing is Hands-On projects and
networking those are the two things that
I think are super crucial Network when I
say Network I don't mean networking like
the technical term I mean like Community
I think the power of using LinkedIn as
you're learning the power of
um really getting involved in Virtual
meetups user groups there's AWS user
groups in different countries all over
the world that are literally meetups
about about learning cloud and I think
those are just as important with Landing
a job and when I talk about Hands-On
there are many resources we're going to
get into on how to build Hands-On
projects but those are really crucial to
land the job certifications could give
you a guide Hands-On will help you land
a job uh hands-on experience and a lot
of those projects could be done without
working for a company
um it's about really doing something
you're passionate about picking projects
you want to stick to and building that
skill set and a lot of times you'll land
a job before you you you need to
continue the journey to the point that
you could land a job and you will
continue learning on the job but to land
the job really it's important to look at
a role and work backwards from the role
look at the requirements of the role a
title doesn't mean as much as like the
title in a company right I would do the
research of also speaking inside
companies that are in your area in a
company you work for even if it's an I
started in a non-technical role that was
a TV production role and I literally
emailed HR asking for whose Works in in
the who's the head of the digital team
and ended up contacting and asking to
Shadow them and learning what their
roles were and then asking them what
they needed because I knew that the
first job is harder to get so sometimes
you need to learn the skills to land the
job and get your foot in the door and
then it's easier to to then continue on
so another trick that trick but
suggestion just a quick one and this
kind of goes into advice on learning
um
use when I say use the network you have
like start a Meetup that you're learning
you want to learn something start a meet
up in your in a company work for in a
student group you're in and learn
together by doing that you will increase
your network you give yourself a
deadline and you end up knowing about
all these other opportunities like I
started meetups inside where I worked
but I was not working in cloud and
that's how I was able to then meet and
understand the other roles and what
they're doing what they need right and
you also gain that trust so that's just
a quick overview
um but in general uh I there's a lot of
resources depending where you're
starting if you're a student it's
different if you're non-technical if you
want to work maybe help desk and go that
direction you kind of have I know it's
broad but um looking at the role and
working backwards I can't stress that
enough
um
so and then if you don't know what role
you kind of have to brought it I I like
using the CCP certification the ASA
certification to kind of gives you those
guides but um as far as advice and
learning AWS Cloud
um do we want to start with
certification tips
um or uh more like in general
um that's a good point yeah
certification tips uh that could be good
to start with because you know yeah
um so I feel like yeah with
certifications
um one thing I think in general for um
no matter if you're doing like any of
the AWS certifications
um I really recommend leaving padded
time to dive deep into places you you
know like a lot of people study Theory
don't and don't do the Hands-On as much
and I think that's where it's good to
use it as a guide to then build deeper
projects so
for example like as you're doing the
labs there's workshops that AWS
um where they have like a lot of
different
like Hands-On guides and projects if you
want to have like ideas in any space
that you're like networking or different
things and um I think it really helps
um when you're trying to Niche into
something specific or go deeper in
something specific Hands-On also skill
build or diabetes I'm just sending the
links on the chat here but um
there's nothing like Hands-On projects I
think the point of theory you need kind
of it's like a dance with both but
um until you do the Hands-On projects
you don't experience certain things
um that are job specific that you could
then speak on in an interview because
even if you land an interview you have
to be able to speak on it right and um
it's really important the other thing is
open source
um there are a lot of like different
open source projects you can contribute
to that gives you community that gives
you like
um a way to kind of earn trust that
gives you a network I recommend going on
the AWS twitch Channel there's an open
source show as well where um they
literally go every week live and there's
a lot of like twitch in general has like
even like
um Hands-On projects live you could ask
questions on the channel
um all that different like there's a lot
there's even like certification study
groups so I recommend using that
um as well when you're trying to kind of
build that hands-on experience and I'm
I'm going to whoops I'm going to send
the link
um right
sorry I know that's I'm throwing a lot
of resources at you but it's uh it's
it's one of those things you have to
identify how you learn best
um if you learn through gaming maybe do
Cloud Quest if you learn through you
know like there's Cloud Quest is a is a
game where you can learn Cloud skills um
through a game um it's by
skillbuilder.aws
um and I'll send that site as well right
but I really think you have to identify
how you prefer to learn
and what jobs you're aiming for and if
you don't know what job you're aiming
for that could evolve as well like your
goals could evolve but like it gets you
to that next step
um and the network networking Community
people kind of wait until the end
they're waiting to have like this x
amount of experiences to the network of
the community when you learn something
even intro right you're learning
something fundamental don't think you're
not experienced enough to share about
that thing sometimes teaching is the
best way to learn
in the weirdest way but it's true it is
yep
and I know I'm talking a lot so let's
see
I'll pause here for a second
oh no that's all good uh you mentioned
so many resources and I think the good
part of it is like the answer is it
really depends on you know things like
your learning style what role you want
to become Cloud Quest was a good shout
out because I haven't actually mentioned
Cloud quests in any of my videos so far
but you know it's a free game you can
you know go through this adventure and
then pass the cloud practitioner exam
afterwards because it you know covers
the same content as the cloud
practitioner exam so that could be one
way to learn
um if you're more into just like reading
documentation you know there's a lot of
documentation of white papers out there
to help you with your study and then
yeah as you all know I've recommended so
many video courses before so that could
be another way to learn
um but yeah it really depends on where
you are in your journey and you know
what's best for you but since we've
talked about everything in like a very
very general sense so we're going to
start answering some questions from the
live chat because everyone has you know
everyone comes from a very specific
background and some people have actually
shared with us their specific situation
and then hopefully we can answer some of
those questions and provide you with
some more tailored advice so the first
question we have here Linda is this
person is working as a technical support
in an ISP and they're interested in
starting a career in cloud and want to
know if it's the right choice for them
and if they can get a job I know this
question is still pretty General but
maybe we can talk upon you know like
yeah how do you know if cloud is right
for you if you had some technical
experience in the past right yeah I know
and I I think it's a great question
because I think a lot of people when
they don't experience something specific
they kind of want to know is it for me
right like I remember when I was trying
to start even in encoding jobs like I
was like is this for me and I think the
best way to answer that is trying to
build projects using it and if you're
looking from a job standpoint if there's
available jobs I would really use
LinkedIn and dip and your own company to
see if there's demand for it right
um I cloud is very broad I could tell
you that it's not it there's so many
rules within that so is if the question
of if there it's needed it's absolutely
needed but whether your local area has
the jobs that you would enjoy that could
vary by rule right like that really
depends on what they're looking for what
phases the businesses are in the area
um my like I think the best way is
really trying different projects and
trying to get involved locally if you're
already working a technical role check
in your own company or any any like kind
of companies in the area like if you're
working like in a technical role Reach
Out Try I really believe in prioritizing
trying to move or use a company you're
already in even if you're not in that
role to figure out that trying to ask if
you could Shadow teams try and ask if
you could like get advice you were in
the company so if you are in a company
and they are using cloud services I
would position it as wanting to upskill
right and just ask advice always like
you know I think when you come with
advice angle
um and shadowing angle
um it really helps because the heart
it's harder to kind of like try things
right in a new place like it's when
you're like you have like a network it's
easier to kind of like ask this question
so
um for me my my kind of my way of doing
it was
um going in a company I was in even if I
was not working in that role and if it
didn't exist I started a Meetup about it
and was able to find the people that did
want to learn that and then got my next
job because of it so
um
I really would explore what what cloud
roles are in your current company and if
they're if that's not an option
um what is in the area I would go on
LinkedIn or indeed or all these
different jobs and see what what skills
are they looking for but cloud in
general it's very much in demand the
question is what kind of sorry I I know
that's Rob I like it depends what your
location is and what jobs are currently
in demand in the area
yep because sometimes when people think
about AWS Cloud roles they think about
jobs within AWS but you know a lot of
companies these days use cloud and they
have Cloud Engineers uh technical
support maybe even Solutions Architects
within their own company so it would be
good to use that as opportunity if your
company has those roles to Shadow them
and you know learn from them just to see
if it's like a right the right role for
you also Cloud today
I mean Cloud used to be like today you
could be a front-end developer and
you're using cloud services you're using
amplify you're using like it I think it
really
is is Broad to the point that like now
everything's kind of ingrained in that
so it really depends the role you're
looking for and then what skill sets
like even now as a web developer knowing
cloud is kind of like
it adds a lot of depth so it doesn't
look like it's some magic to you and
then you're also you're able to use it
to build there's a lot of no code Loco
tools that even knowing how to use those
are important if you're in machine
learning using sagemaker you know like
there's a lot of different like things
that are now part of cloud that we're
maybe not considered cloud in the past
and now like it's such a broad term
today like
I think it really depends on the type of
area you want to focus on whether it be
more devops or you know from web
development or uh solution architect or
like the things you would enjoy and and
you could evolve you're not boxing
yourself in you know like just because
you pick a role now doesn't mean that's
what you're gonna box yourself and I'm
evolving every day we're all evolving
every day that's a beauty with tech we
constantly all have to learn we're
professional students
exactly yeah
um and speaking of you know how cloud is
everywhere you know there's the three
main clouds AWS gcp and Azure and a lot
of people are always kind of like what
cloud should I learn first or should I
learn all three clouds like or should I
dive deep into one so we do have a
question from the chat um that's asking
about this exact question which is yeah
how do I pick which Cloud to learn and
yeah should I go broad or should I go
deep what are your thoughts on that I
really think
um pick pick one when you're starting
like I don't think like trying to like
do different like I think there's
fundamentals they're kind of similar on
each like when you're studying them and
if you're not familiar with Cloud pick
one I would choose it based on the need
of the jobs and the things in your Arena
if you're working in a company that's
using a specific Cloud for provider
learn that cloud provider because you
have a better way to then like
transition into that I work at AWS my
company before this that I was working
in was using AWS it was a natural
progression for me
um and I personally like also was
another thing I was in a um a program
called the AWS Community Builders
program if you're learning cloud and you
want community and you enjoy sharing
knowledge as you're learning I highly
recommend the AWS Community Builders
program you get free courses and perks
and like a community you learn with and
just I it's hard to even explain like
how powerful it is if you are in the
Journey of learning cloud I recommend
applying to this program
um if you are looking to do AWS Cloud
specifically
um it's I'm going to share the link and
I'm sorry I'm typing this
um
um but I have the links are open right
now they actually just opened uh
yesterday so
um
I just entered the link I just have it
ready here so oh perfect okay because I
I wasn't sure I look with two screens oh
oops okay oh that's okay like whenever
you mention resources I'll just drop
them because I think it's easier than
multitasking yeah I'm like trying to
multitask I'm terrible at it at this
moment
um but uh yeah I think um trying to
figure out the skill sets you could
always evolve like a lot of the skills
are transferable right
um so I I I think it's less about less
about you don't want to get into an
action paralysis right you know
um where I see a lot of people like
trying to figure out and they're trying
to make the choices and it's hard
because they're trying to figure out the
full road map and it's not it's you kind
of have to sometimes take the next step
and Trust the process
um you know I I it's hard easier said
than done but I think especially with
cloud like and anything in Tech really
it kind of it really depends on also
like what tools a company's using but
another thing I will say is if you're
learning a specific cloud provider and
you want to get a job like like with
other skill sets it's transferable so
don't overly like think through that
like I would use what is being used in
your vicinity in your industry that
you're in or the industry you want to be
in in your dream job like I would kind
of like
pick based on what you could get a job
in in the area right
yeah I think that might also fall under
common mistakes which is you know that
analysis paralysis were like what how
should I learn and they end up like you
know spending too much time dwelling and
you know end up not learning anything so
yeah
with question number three I'd like to
start um by answering this now because
we've gotten a few questions in the chat
asking you know we know that hands-on
experience is important but how exactly
do we gain hands-on experience so I know
one way we mentioned is through project
uh projects there's also internships and
trying to you know shadow people and
then try and like help them out uh what
are some other ways you think they could
build hands-on experience and you know
for the ones we mentioned are there some
examples you can recommend yeah so I
think um there's a a lot of ways I think
open source is another great way
um there's a lot of Open Source projects
there's actually labels and beginner
issues versus like more complex issues
so you could find like pull like issues
that are open on open source projects
that are more beginner beginner style
um I I think with Hands-On also my rule
of thumb is build something build
something you're passionate about and
that you would enjoy talking about in an
interview it's better to build a project
that you go deeper on and like
you are excited about the product and
you wake up in the morning and enjoy it
because that's what's going to keep you
consistent
um I will say though like there's so
many projects um like there's things
that you could
um like for example if you want to do
like Ci CD pipeline you could do it on
your own resume and make a site and make
a CI CD pipeline for your resume you
know what I'm saying you don't have to
be like waiting for yourself to be in a
company to make those projects
um but chat Bots are a great way you
know like depending on the style of
things you enjoy to do I would say that
too like that makes you that shines
through in like interviews when you're
speaking on something and it makes you
also go deeper because you're you care
about trying to build something fun
um but for me personally like sometimes
I tell people if they aren't sure where
to start start with like hosting your
resume on a site and uh make a CI CD
pipeline I think there's a there's
actually um
Force Brazil
um made like this kind of like
step-by-step guide for that
um start with things that are more like
attainable from the skills that you're
coming from so if you enjoy uh if let's
say you have a little bit of experience
in JavaScript start with amplify if you
are really excited about machine
learning start with sagemaker
um I also want to send over a link of
the student Hub and the reason I want to
send it is there are four different
places to start right at the top with
Hands-On work I think it summarizes it
well so I'm going to send this site even
if you're not a student I recommend
looking at this page because I think if
you're really not sure there's like four
different projects here that could kind
of get you started in the journey and
you could kind of dabble and look
through
um workshops that AWS like I mean if you
love coffee you could build your own
serverless Espresso Bar
um if you love you there's so many ways
to then take something and make it fun
so I think that's really important I'm
looking at the comments here
um
and I know this is a broad answer
um but that's because there's so many
things you could build and with so many
different skill sets so if you
um I would build the projects for roles
that you're aiming for and if you're not
sure start with one of the beginner type
like four types of different rules four
types of different like things machine
learning or um serverless or uh that I
just sent in the link but
um
I think it really needs to excite you
that's that's the point
um it could be you know you like music
so you want to build something music you
want uh you like I would look at ways
that you could really build a product
that you're excited to speak on that
will shine through way more
um yeah you know either something that
you're interested in or even better
something that you're both interested in
and actually addresses a problem I've
seen so many project examples that
people have helped out a family business
by hosting their website onto AWS onto
the cloud and I thought that was a
pretty good good way of you know just as
a cloud beginner still being able to add
value to different businesses and people
around you that's really cool I I know a
few people like went to non-profits and
like you know helped them out and like
we're learning through helping helping
out like their communities like exactly
like I think
um not being scared also to not know how
to do something and knowing that you
will figure it out is really important
you don't
I think like we're always learning
believe me like every time when I
shifted from a web developer to an SRE I
learned a lot of the stuff on the job so
don't feel like you
have to know everything to start
sometimes you just have to think about
the small Next Step
and not overwhelm yourself with a
staircase you know so
um
I think that's the other thing action
paralysis happens a lot when people try
to go Hands-On like they think cloud and
they go and if you're leading with like
hey I'm gonna try to put a website on
amplify and like I'm just I just want to
put my own little like website like
start there and you could that
introduces you to serverless I started
with building an Alexa skill I was
passionate about um uh like I wanted to
build a trivia game and I built an Alexa
skill on the Alexa so I mean there's
different kinds of things but I was
excited about it right like you love uh
Game of Thrones build an Alexa Game of
Thrones trivia game I mean like you know
uh I think the sometimes you could take
the same technology and make different
purposes for it but I think when you're
passionate if you're solving a problem
it just also looks good for even job
Landing too
yeah we have another question in the
chat uh asking about so you know we
talked a lot about how to learn Cloud
but then you know before Cloud sometimes
people would also want to learn about
the I.T fundamentals just getting a good
idea of you know networking compute
storage and other it domains so do you
have any advice on how people can learn
the foundations before learning cloud or
do you think it's going to be kind of
like a mix of both you you learn cloud
and then if there's anything you don't
know you can learn the fundamentals
around it and it's yes do you think it's
going to be like a linear process yeah
so and I think it really depends on
where this person's starting if
somebody's going into for example help
desk type job right
um maybe they or CIS admin you know like
they might gear into something that's
not necessarily like fully cloud like
you know networking Linux programming
let's say you're even starting just with
coding right
um I think the key the key here is
to me like it really depends on where
you're coming I started out with
programming I'm giving my own example
here because like I'm just speaking like
personal experience like I started out
programming and then learned Cloud but I
know a lot of people who started with
cloud and then learned coding I do think
that core fundamentals is important I
think networking at least on a
fundamental level is important so I
recommend like the networking Linux and
python or a programming language I do
think um you could do it simultaneously
you don't have to do all three I think
it's more like depending on the role you
think you will enjoy doing and again if
you don't know where to start my
recommendation is just starting with
fundamentals of cloud and then maybe
instead of your next step being you know
let's say you start with the cloud
practitioner certification right that
gives you Theory okay it's just
introducing you to Cloud The Next Step
might be I realize I need networking
fundamentals so you might go then to
networking fundamentals and then maybe
to ASA right ASA covers networking
fundamental networking and Theory a
little bit but not like it's all
multiple choice right it's not giving
you fully all of that and then you could
go to workshops that AWS and do a
workshop about networking right so I
think for me networking is really
important I think think you end up
having to understand in some capacity
and programming I think programming you
don't have to be a heavy programmer
sometimes you might be doing light
scripting but there's some core things
you might need to know the basics of the
order really depends on how you learn
don't feel like just because somebody
did it in one order you have to do it in
one order my favorite way is get to the
point that you can build a Hands-On
project learn what you need to make the
Hands-On Project work you will learn
everything else through building
Hands-On projects because at the end if
you have to build Hands-On you're like
and you're curious about it that to me
is the fastest way learn enough
fundamentals to start building dive in
from there fill in the gaps of where
you're lacking depth and you might even
land a drop through that and continue
learning on the job so
um so it's it's I know it's like it's
kind of like a balancing dance but I do
think if I was choosing anything
fundamentals it is networking and some
you know Linux and programming but not
like it doesn't need to be in depth it
just like get yourself familiar with the
fundamentals
mm-hmm yeah do you have any examples of
things that you've learned on the job as
a developer Advocate yeah I think it
would be great to show people that yeah
you don't have to know everything
starting before the yeah before you
start the role um so I'll get you an
example on so I went from web
development to
um site reliability engineering
um and how I how I did that like I'm
giving that example because I think it's
more relevant from like uh cloud like
developer advocacy we'll we'll get into
what it what we do but like I think that
was the transition for me that was
coming into Cloud new so when I was a
web developer I was really excited about
the cloud but my job did not Encompass
any like any cloud services I was
building products and I was then like
you know pushing in something made it go
into a server and I had no idea what was
happening and it was like magic right
um and then I got really excited about
the cloud and I started through Cloud
certifications which was a guide but I
had no hands-on experience so I started
building Alexa apps and starting to kind
of get involved with like putting the
code I was kind of shipping into lambdas
and like getting more into serverless
and stuff like that but um as I was kind
of like trying to transition over they
needed like sres and sres really deal
with observability I don't know if
you're familiar with like cyber server
reliability engineering but the skill
set I needed for that that I knew like
some fundamentals of using cloud
services and stuff like that but I did
not know how to like do the monitoring
and you know I wasn't using let's say
terraform as much or cloud formation as
much so I had to learn like
infrastructures code a lot more that I
learned on the job I didn't I I got to
the point where I landed the job and
then on the job I got this book called
The SRE workbook and literally went
through that on the job so but I think
also with Cloud you'll see people
getting Cloud jobs maybe they don't have
experience even like at a specific Cloud
um uh provider but they have
transferable skills like I knew how to
program I understood the fundamentals of
cloud I built stuff on cloud and there's
so many services I you know I don't
think anybody could name all the
services these days so it's it's knowing
how to navigate they want to know that
you can navigate it right
um it's you're not always going to know
everything on a job and I think Lucy you
have a similar experience of learning on
the job that I don't know if you want to
I I watch one of your YouTube but
totally totally stopping your YouTube
videos
um and yeah um I I think you you don't
have to know everything you're going to
learn so much on the job like I had to
build dashboards on datadot with datadog
you know I didn't know that before the
job
yeah um honestly yeah I was very
overwhelmed before starting the role
because you hear about Solutions
Architects uh needing to know all of the
services and being like a technical
advisor helping customers navigate all
of the services and the best practices
and I looked at a list of AWS services
and there's over 200
um but then a lot of what you mentioned
today really resonated with me and
hopefully the audience as well in that a
lot of it is like you learn on the job
and also it's sometimes like just in
time learning as well so I'll have a
customer that I need to talk to next
week that wants to talk about some
service that I have no idea about but
what I'll do is I'll do research on it
I'll ask some specialists in the company
or I'll just ask my colleagues for some
help if there's any questions I'm not
too sure about but you have a sort of
buffer period every time you're asked to
do something or learn something and
that's an opportunity to learn exactly
that
um because if you learn everything
theoretically you're gonna forget it
anyways if you don't regularly apply
apply it so it's great to just you know
be familiar with maybe let's say like 50
of it be comfortable with like you know
when you apply for a job if you feel
like it aligns with you like 50
um based on your skills and experiences
I would recommend still applying anyways
you don't have to 100 fit every single
role and requirement and know everything
before you actually take that jump
because as you mentioned every like not
everything but most of it is on the job
it's all about just learning the
foundational up the Foundations at the
start yep so then there are common
mistakes uh we mentioned a few common
mistakes yeah what are some other
mistakes you've seen for cloud beginners
because I know you make a lot of
Instagram rules and tick tocks and a lot
of people comment below and you know you
help them with their Cloud Journey what
are some mistakes you see people make
um maybe like last year or this year
yeah so a lot so a couple I'll name like
four
um the one that I think we talk about we
talked a little bit like right people
study Theory and don't go into Hands-On
um they get scared I think my favorite
way to start is doing Labs just do Labs
even if you don't have a project and
then build on those labs like start with
Labs there's AWS educate.com they have
Labs skillbuilder.ws has labs I'll we'll
put the links amazon.quicklabs Labs has
Labs stuff like um just start with Labs
if you're not inspired yet and I was
saying like find something you're
inspired but like to get to that point
do Labs start just following
instructions and then you're building on
top of that but start diving in
um the SEC um the second thing I would
say
um is like being get networking with a
community like
I can't stress it enough
you land a job not just because of your
skill set
you also land a job when you give back
to the community especially in Tech
Tech is all about like sharing
information and building on each other's
Innovation when you network and you when
I say Network I don't mean like the
corporate like I mean just really if
you're authentically like right putting
your notes up on a Blog and now and
involving yourself other people with
your Learning Journey in a way that
you're comfortable with using LinkedIn
to document your journey or stuff like
that I think you will find people
invested in your success and you will
also either find other people learning
um and it is a crucial part of like also
lending a job
um because you will have an easier time
finding opportunities if you put
yourself it doesn't need to be that you
have to do content creation it could be
like helping people on stack overflow
when you're uh having a problem or like
just being involved in the community or
um following people
um in in LinkedIn that are posting about
this stuff and interacting with those
posts and like kind of learning through
that and and building that Network
because
there's so many times like I saw people
like they not only had the skill set and
passion to learn they wanted to give
back to the community and I think when
you have that person like when you show
that that's how you kind of build with
each other that isn't isn't that the
point of what we're doing right like
we're innovating and to innovate you
have to share knowledge and you find the
mediums you're comfortable with if it's
blogging if it's commenting on things
and like stack Overflow if it's helping
people I mean there's so many different
ways open source but I really think
trying to and never feel you're not like
experienced enough like
no I think the way people explain
something as a beginner I can never
explain again how I explain something as
a beginner now right because I don't
have the same Outlook anymore and I
forgot what it was like and I think you
have such a power when you're starting
out to document that it could be your
own notes but then you decide to publish
it and you don't know how many people
you're helping to and I think it also
when you have to do to teach you make
you learn more because you're putting it
out there
so I mean that's just one tip like I
just think like build a community and by
doing that I mean getting involved in
the community right that was and the AWS
Community Builders program is another
option or there's a lot of them I'm
talking AWS specifically but in General
open source is huge I think that's a
huge way to do that and
um or or like helping out with you know
different
um
forearms and stuff like that so
um that's like another tip actually I
think we talked about the third one is
paralysis like action paralysis like I
see so many people be like
when I get to this point like I'm not
and I I think people get nervous to
share their stuff or or like
build like they want to learn like I
think people have to like dive in more
so and do it in a way that you're
comfortable so
I think we see that a lot I think people
also feel like they need all these
different skills to apply where I think
they should start applying when they get
like to a certain point like you're
going to learn a lot on the job just get
to a point that you meet like some of
the fundamental requirements and have
Hands-On projects you know
um and yeah and the fourth one I would
say is not working backwards from Rules
I feel like so many people trying to get
in are like just taking this blueprint
of like uh even a solution Arctic or
anything and like they're not looking at
the actual job postings I really
recommend studying the job postings
sometimes and like yeah I'm going to
meet up and speak and listening to
people actually in the industry and
understanding what they're doing because
it's hard every you can have the same
role in three different companies and
it's not the same things
um yeah I think one advice I always like
to share with people is not submit a
generic resume to every role and you
know job descriptions will be really
important because it gives you a lot of
clues about what they're looking for
they pretty much write down a few
sentences what the ideal candidate is
and you want to include a lot of the
keywords and you know the skills into
your own resume uh the reason I
mentioned this is because there's
actually a question from the audience of
asking how did your resume look like
when you applied to foxcorp versus
Amazon
so I think it evolved a lot
um for me
so a lot of I was kind of creating also
a lot of content and I think
it's an unspoken thing that helps right
like when you are
teaching and learning putting yourself
out there you're putting yourself a bit
in a vulnerable position but you're also
like learning a lot as far as what the
resume looked like it evolved like I I
had like some projects I was doing that
were not corporate like for example I
made chat Bots Alexa skills put stuff on
serverless so like when I was kind of
like transitioning into a more Cloud
world my projects were very like
not things that were Enterprise skill I
had Enterprise scale experience when I
worked Enterprise in Cloud but I think
so that that was the difference in the
resume I also did certs as a guide so
that was part of it um but I did
transition to Cloud within the same
company so I didn't have to like my
I guess like my resume like kind of just
like additionally had more projects that
I was doing a lot of web development
projects and I did include all that
there's so many transferable skills like
when you're going into Cloud you don't
just need Cloud skills right there's
communication skills there's different
different ends of tech
um I mean even if you like even if you
work in something that's not Tech
there's transferable skills in there so
I wouldn't not mention it in your resume
I would just maybe to fit it all in make
it like succinct like what were the
action items
um but I worked in TV production and
there was a lot of like understanding
the user right like I was building
products that I understood the user so
don't underestimate also the industries
you're in if you like healthcare
um understanding the user is just as
important when you're working in a
company like I think people like
companies like that it might it might
not be a requirement but it definitely
helps so
um depending on the industry you want to
work in like just because you're in a
different industry
that that's very much still like
applicable
yeah another question in the chat this
actually maybe we can answer after the
question on the um on the list which is
what does a developer Advocate do at AWS
because uh this question the child asks
us about how you navigate ambiguity and
you know unknown factors in your
position which I think a lot of the
roles in Tech it's a lot about
navigating antibody the world changes
every day honestly so so yeah funny
story I'd love to hear about it yeah
when I worked as an SRE like I felt like
I was doing things as an infrastructure
engineer it was like it the rules kind
of like the lines kind of blur right
um I kind of take it as
we like giving labels to things to make
it easier for us to understand but the
truth is we're constantly evolving
nothing stagnant not even your role full
stack Engineers used to be a thing now
it's like front and backup because
that's not really a thing as much like
it's not as much a thing but like
companies can't hire just full stack
Engineers like it's scale like it
there's too many things to learn under
that right devops broad like all these
different things just brought in and are
are like titles above uh some people are
mentioning AI like there's so many jobs
are going to be created that don't even
exist yet because of AI yeah okay so
like the the I think like looking more
at the tasks and less kind of trying to
marry the title because you're just
evolving and we're building stuff I just
look at it as I'm building things and I
don't care what you call it I'm building
something if I need to do this I'm doing
this if I need to do that I'm doing that
you know like it it's kind of like a lot
of things are not boxed in some teams
because you evolve and even within the
team they might have different cultures
and philosophies on how there's their
they're running uh the team so
um there could be a lot of ambiguity in
my job
um my job has a very variety of
different skill sets
um I work as a developer Advocate and I
think the best way to describe it is I'm
still building I'm at I'm advocating on
behalf of developers right I guess I
know developer Advocate but um this used
to be called maybe technical evangelists
or other terms
um and I'm still building products but
I'm not building for prod I'm building
for educational purposes as much I'm not
building for product right I'm not
shipping to prod I think that's like a
main difference
um and I'm writing a lot internally I'm
advocating on behalf of what we want to
see I'm working with service teams
internally and then I'm also like
working externally to amplify different
things to amplify opportunities to
understand like different issues people
are having so but within developer
advocacy there are also a lot of
different types of developer Advocates
there are General list type ad developer
Advocates there are people who are more
niched into like
um deep into machine learning or you
know data science like there's different
types of developer Advocates
um you could be at AWS you could be
Regional you could be based on a
specific region you could be a
generalist or you could be a specialist
and there's some developer Advocates
that work with a specific service they
might work with amplify right so they
specifically are Developer advocates for
example afraid of us Amplified so
I think that I know it's broad we the
skill sets like I'm doing everything
from a lot of writing to to speaking to
building to
um looking at stack Overflow forums like
I mean it it varies and also you get to
choose a bit too depending on the type
of role you have like you might be doing
more video you might be doing more
writing you might be running uh running
programs to pipeline certain things you
might be running the like Community
Builder program like there are so many
different types and really the the point
is to be an ally to developers the point
of my job is to be an ally to developers
to Advocate on the behalf of developers
to figure out how we can make things
better
um for them and also help internally and
amplify messaging outside and reach have
things reach our developers so I guess
that's kind of like because I'm a
generalist in North America but like
that could vary based on service too and
type of developer Advocate I hope that
was I know it's like and it's ambiguous
just like everything in Tech
no it's yeah every role in Tech is a
little bit ambiguous especially you know
roles in large companies like AWS where
there is this umbrella term like
Solutions architect or developer
Advocate but there are so many different
flavors of them and so many different
types like for example I was a
journalist Solutions architect but we
had specialist Solutions Architects
focusing on a set of services or we had
partner Solutions architects who didn't
work directly with customers who focused
more towards working with AWS Partners
so it I guess the umbrella term for
Solutions Architects was where the
trusted technical advisor for customers
as they go along the journey with the
cloud uh you know you mentioned there's
like an umbrella sort of phrase like
what developer Advocates generally don't
do but um yeah you did a really good job
at explaining that overall which is good
so
there's a few more questions in the chat
um and when I know we're closing in on
the hour so what I want to focus on
because there's a few questions on this
topic which is AI and chat GPT and I
guess maybe not so much like how AI will
replace jobs or things like that but
more towards how we can use Ai and you
know the new technologies that have been
released as a way to learn Cloud I know
one thing I've discovered is you can
someone put the certification exam
questions into chat GPT and they were
able to answer it and pass the AWS
Solutions Arctic associate exam which I
thought was pretty cool so are there any
ways you can think of that you can use
AI to uh you know help you on your Cloud
Journey yeah so I I like I'll prefix by
saying I look at at like AI right now as
an assistant I don't I think it makes me
more productive I think it'll make us
more productive I think new jobs yes
will there be jobs that might disappear
yes are there I think this is an opinion
on pre-facing this is my opinion
um I think um there are also a lot of
jobs that will be created
um because of this and I I look at it as
like the same thing as like no code Loco
tools and all these different types of
tooling we have if you look at what even
web development was years ago versus now
you could do it way faster are there
less web developers I don't I don't
think there are I think it's just like
the type of job and the type of output
is different
um the the ability to get into it is
different because you could get into it
faster because you might not need to
know everything under the hood to get
started doesn't mean that that you won't
want to know it but like you don't need
to know everything to get started and to
get products out
um I personally love it even like let's
say let's talk about Hands-On projects
right so many people are asking about
Hands-On projects AWS I would literally
I I was doing this the other day I was
asking Chad gbt about ideas and it gave
me some ideas about Hands-On projects
for AWS and then I asked I prompted it
back with
specifics and then I looked at a roadmap
you know like don't take it as of course
it's also how you put the prompts but I
think really look at it as an assistant
when you're stuck whenever I'm stuck
even with writing like it kind of gives
me ideas sometimes they're good
sometimes they're more too broad but
then I'm like okay be more specific it's
like it it's like it's like somebody I
could talk to a little bit I know you
know how we have ducks and we talk to
them right into coding it's kind of like
that a little bit but like except this
is much smarter but um you know it's
it's one of those things I look at it
that way it's been helping me
um also when I'm kind of trying to
figure out more broad ideas or like kind
of stuck in lack of inspiration or
motivation in certain respects
um I think if you're looking for
Hands-On um AWS projects I would kind of
ask for it and then prompted back with a
list let's say it tells you oh build
right we were saying Cloud resume
there's a cloud resume challenge build a
resume with a you know with cloud and
hosted on S3 and you know or or add
pipelining to it or add all these
different features to it and then you'll
be like okay so how would you do that
with XNX services or how would you do
that or which Services you know kind of
prompted with different things it could
help you as a starting point right it
would save view time and research it's
not that this information doesn't
necessarily exist online it's that you
finding it takes longer so I'm saying
this in the perspective of where you are
like how to use it for like navigating
career
um in general I can't predict the future
but I think right now like to me it's
it's more of a an assistant and and I
think there are going to be a lot of new
jobs in Tech because of it
yeah really exciting time to be a
balance uh it's it's cool because yeah
I've realized that I could start using
chat GPT to write my YouTube scripts and
a lot of the use case that you mentioned
I was trying to play around with it as
well you know uh using it as a way to
build projects because I remember asking
it uh what are top what are the top five
Cloud projects I can build on AWS and
then they'll ask them like you know for
this project what are the exact steps
I'll need to follow and I know there's
limitations in that chat DPT was uh I
think it doesn't go through anything
that's after 2021 or something but yeah
you know it gives a really good starting
point like there are still some
limitations to you to AI but I think you
know we'd really encourage using it as a
learning tool and as an assistant as an
assistant for learning cloud exactly and
and here's the thing you might get
instructions from Child GPT and when you
try to do them there are going to be
maybe issues doing it other things so I
think like when you're like there's
gonna be other tools you use it's very
much like a complimentary thing I
wouldn't take it as like you you know
everything right it is limited it
doesn't like it doesn't have like the
updated data you could also connect to
the API and use some things too I think
you're going to see a lot of different
Services also come out that are more
specific it's going to improve but um I
would use it for your goals and like
help it get you out of a slump if you're
stuck right
um I think that that gives you some
guidance give you some ideas give you
some inspiration and then then always
add your personality to it I think the
thing is like it could give you a
step-by-step on a Hands-On project then
you're saying how do I make it about
like something I enjoy right you could
always take kind of a project and make
it about it more specific topic or a
YouTube script right Lucy like there's
personality involved in YouTube scripts
a script is nice it's the research we we
start to do but beyond that it's the
person and the delivery and other things
that maybe AI can't necessarily they
can't be you at this point right it's
like it's like yeah it's different it's
like you might have like the stuff but
it's also like what else are you adding
to that and it saves research time sure
right but that means you'll see more of
Lucy or more of me or more of other
people because we're able to output and
get our do our research we would have
done that at Google right before if it's
something we aren't necessarily on right
so it's yeah I think we haven't got
gotten to that point where you know like
it's like a complete AI person talking
to you
um yeah I saw some of that I saw like
Synthesia Synthesia oh yes I pronounce
that one that's crazy yeah I'm excited
I'm definitely also learning I'm
probably gonna
also you know I'm I'm kind of in that
phase where I'm learning a lot but I'm
not machine learning I'm not AI but I'm
learning about it and I'll be
documenting that too as I'm learning
with you with everyone same you know but
I I think it's exciting we're always
learning something new and that's the
coolest part about our about being in
tech and and we're never stopping to
learn that's that's what's exciting
um yeah I think that's all the time we
have for today Linda uh but I wanted to
ask you what are your three main
takeaways uh that you'd like to leave
with the viewers for this conversation
um yeah any three tips that they can
take away to learn AWS cloud in 2023.
yeah I would start with mindset
um
I think so much of learning anything in
Tech
is being is learning to be comfortable
with being uncomfortable
you don't need to know everything so
just know like like you could you could
do it and you need to take it step by
step and that could evolve you could
have a goal and that could evolve so I
think that's that's one uh the second
thing is make sure you're doing Hands-On
try to get Hands-On as fast as you can
even if you're learning theory even if
it's through Labs or different things
um and the third thing is community find
like Network Community today we have so
many social platforms to do that in do
it in the way that you're comfortable in
somebody's Journey doesn't you don't
have to copy somebody's Journey you
commit you're the artist of your own
life make it yours my journey I didn't
know anybody who was doing my journey
and now maybe I do know a few people who
did a similar Journey like it's it
there's no rules and that's the beauty
of this industry it's overwhelming
because maybe you don't know the path I
know some people like really want the
step by step but I think trusting the
process and knowing that the beauty is
that it's a lot of a lot of it is open
there's so much need there's so much
evolving of tech jobs those skill sets
are transferable so don't feel like
you're boxed and don't feel like you
have to know everything so I know that
was a kind of three that was meshed but
I think so much of it is like Community
mindset and um trying to do more
Hands-On stuff work so Community mindset
more Hands-On nice yeah those are some
really inspiring takeaways so thank you
so much Linda for your time today and
for joining us on the cloud hour on the
technology show so yeah for the viewers
uh hopefully you found this video
helpful and don't forget we have another
live stream tomorrow all about educate
certifications
um Linda I'll leave a link as well to
your website so people can follow you
and Linda is it was such an honor to be
um Lisa you're amazing and thank you for
all you do for the community you are
incredible and I'm so glad I got to be
on on the show with you so
oh thank you so much this was really fun
um I'll just link to your website so are
you active mainly on Instagram and Tick
Tock is that where people can find you
yeah Instagram Tick Tock LinkedIn
Twitter the master I don't know like I'm
all over I I tend to be like Instagram
is probably my primary and then uh and
Tick Tock and also lately I've been
along LinkedIn too
LinkedIn yeah yeah
awesome okay so all the links should be
within the website right yeah all my
social channels are there but
um and yeah like let's let's continue
the conversation I'm wishing you all the
Good Vibes and luck on your Journeys um
it is definitely a space that has a lot
of jobs and demand and there's so much
within that so